"Every member of the Spellman family is born
with a twin!"
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm explaining all the chilling
clues that Sabrina may have a twin who hasn't
been revealed yet!
Keep watching to the end to find out who it's
most likely to be!
Spoilers ahead, so take care if you're not
all caught up, otherwise tap here to watch
my spoiler-free review.
The origins of the twin theory begin right
in the very first episode of Chilling Adventures
in the scene where Sabrina is taking a bath
and suddenly has a vision which transports
her into the woods.
She sees her parents holding a crying baby,
and as she follows them, she discovers two
babies.
She lifts up the blanket covering them and
discovers one of the babies has cloven hooves
rather than human feet like the other child.
The vision disappears, but it leaves us with
a lingering thought as to what it really means.
On one level, this vision of two babies is
symbolic of Sabrina's dual nature – she's
half-witch and half-mortal.
It also represents the decision that Sabrina
wrestles with throughout the first season.
The cloven-hoofed baby on the left represents
her pledging allegiance to the Dark Lord and
the human baby on the right symbolizes the
mortal world Sabrina is trying to avoid leaving
behind.
There's also some foreshadowing of Father
Blackwood's twins in this scene and I'll talk
more about that later.
But in a show like Chilling Adventures, there
are often multiple layers of meaning to important
scenes like this one and fans of the old-school
Sabrina the Teenage Witch sitcom will remember
the line that "every member of the Spellman
family is born with a twin."
Curiously, the Chilling Adventures of Sabrina
has already been exploring the idea of secret
twins in its first season.
In the season 1 finale, Zelda steals away
Blackwood's first-born daughter to raise with
Hilda, leaving the High Priest with what he
thinks is an only son, unaware that little
Judas actually has a twin sister.
In episode 5, "Dreams in a Witch House", the
Spellmans end up being tortured by the sleep
demon Batibat, and during Hilda's nightmare,
Principal Hawthorne reveals that, unknown
to most people except his mother, he had a
twin brother who he absorbed while in the
womb.
During that same nightmare, Hilda has a vision
that she and Zelda have been sewn together
and become inseparable like conjoined twins.
Indeed, it's interesting that the show's production
designer Lisa Soper told website Black Girl
Nerds that she thinks of Hilda and Zelda as
conjoined twins; in fact, that's why she created
that single chair the sisters share in their
office.
Obviously these last two examples in episode
5 are visions and demonstrate Hilda's fear
of a never-ending co-dependence with her sister,
but they also show that Chilling Adventures
is rather interested in the idea of twins
and the storytelling opportunities they afford.
And Zelda taking away Lady Blackwood's daughter
to raise in secret, brings up an interesting
theory that Zelda and Hilda already did this
with another baby.
"We can raise her.
We've done it before."
"We'll keep it a secret, you and I.
Together, as sisters."
Most of us probably assumed Zelda was referring
to how she and Hilda raised Sabrina after
her parents died, but what if she really means
the two aunties secretly raised the other
baby that Sabrina saw in her vision?
Fans of the old-school Sabrina show have seen
something like this before.
In the 90s sitcom, Sabrina meets her identical
twin Katrina at the end of the third season
and it becomes a humorous plot point when
they have to undergo a test to find out which
sibling is the evil one.
The test, of course, reveals Sabrina's sister
Katrina as the evil sibling, and Katrina is
then sent to live in the Twin Cities in a
place known as the "Other Realm".
In that show, the Other Realm is a separate
dimension accessed via a portal and Chilling
Adventures has already shown us a similar
[albeit darker] alternate dimension, Limbo.
Access to Limbo is also through a portal and,
in the scenes we've seen so far, we've also
heard the sound of babies crying there.
We know from Sabrina's mother, Diana, that
unbaptized babies are sent to Limbo, so is
it possible that Sabrina's potential sibling
is stuck in Limbo similar to how Sabrina's
twin, Katrina, was stuck in the Other Realm
in The Teenage Witch show?
There's another possible twin clue in what
Sabrina's mother says to her in Limbo:
"But they took her."
"They took my baby after the baptism."
"Who did?
Are you okay?"
What Diana says to Sabrina could mean a couple
of things.
It could suggest that Sabrina was taken away
from her mother after her Christian baptism
and then promised to the Dark Lord.
Zelda witnessed the pledge Sabrina's father
made to the Dark Lord but she appeared to
be totally unaware of Sabrina's Christian
baptism, so unless Zelda is hiding something
about this, it could be that Diana is referring
to someone else.
Could it be that Diana had a second child,
perhaps a twin of Sabrina, and that baby was
taken away from her?
So, who are the likely candidates for Sabrina's
secret twin?
One possibility is Connor Kemper, the young
warlock who arrived at the Spellman Mortuary
in the first episode.
His death is still a mystery at the end of
season 1 and I'm assuming it's something that
will be tackled in the second season.
Someone who could be an especially interesting
reveal as Sabrina's twin is Nick Scratch.
Nick seems to be a genuine friend of Sabrina's
and he supported her when she objected to
the Feast of Feasts.
However, he could be hiding a darker side
which would play nicely into the idea of an
evil twin.
The clue to his darker nature may be hiding
in plain sight, and it's actually his name,
Nick Scratch.
"Old Nick" and "Old Scratch" are both nicknames
for the Devil, so could he be the dark twin,
or even the devil himself in disguise?
We know Nick is into Sabrina and with Sabrina
looking like she's going a bit wicked at the
end of the season, there's a hint she could
hook up with him in Season 2 [before they
realise they're related, if indeed they are].
So, we might be looking at a Luke and Leia
Skywalker or Jon Snow and Daenerys Targaryen
situation!
Other possibilities for Sabrina's twin could
be the Weird Sister Dorcas, who we've been
told is an orphan, or perhaps a new character
we'll meet in season 2, somebody who's stuck
in Limbo, or possibly even a character from
Riverdale?
Now, do you think Season 2 of Chilling Adventures
will reveal a twin for Sabrina?
I've added a poll where you can vote – just
tap in the top right of this video and after
you've cast your vote you'll be able to see
the results.
Tap left to watch my full breakdown of the
first season of Sabrina plus some other theories
for Season 2 or tap right for the top ten
differences between the new Sabrina and her
90s sitcom.
And if you enjoyed this, remember to subscribe
and leave a thumbs-up for more videos like
this.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!